ORDER IN THE STATE, BUT IT’S A
TREND FOR A LOT OF THOSE RUNNING
STATES HAS PROVEN TO BE.
AND STEVE SCALISE HAS  IS
JOINING ME NOW, THE HOUSE
MINORITY WHIP.
WE’RE AHEAD OF THE WHITE HOUSE
BRIEFING THAT’S COMING UP IN A
FEW MINUTES FROM NOW.
AND ESSENTIALLY WHAT THE
GOVERNOR IS SAYING, WE THINK
IT’S BEST FOR OUR FOLKS TO STAY
HOME, PERIOD, END OF STORY.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THAT?
>> WELL, CLEARLY, YOU’RE SEEING
EACH GOVERNOR HANDLE IT A LITTLE
DIFFERENTLY, BUT THEY’RE ALL
FOLLOWING THE DIRECTION FROM THE
C.D.C. AND THE C.D.C. GUIDELINES
WHICH HAVE BEEN DRIVING A LOT OF
THE DECISIONS THAT GOVERNORS
HAVE BEEN MAKING SO THAT’S WHERE
THOSE DECISIONS HAVE BEEN COMING
FROM, BUT YOU KNOW, IN THE END
IT’S TRYING TO WORK THROUGH AND
HOLD THE THINGS TOGETHER SO THAT
FAMILIES HAVE SOMETHING TO COME
BACK TO.
AND WE’RE WORKING ON A BIG
RELIEF PACKAGE TO TRY TO ENSURE
FOR BOTH FAMILIES AND BUSINESSES
THAT THEY CAN COME BACK.
NEIL: I’M CURIOUS, I MEAN, WE’RE
GOING TO GET MORE DETAILS OF THE
NEXT ROUNDS MUCH STIMULUS AND
MULTIPLE ONES COMING UP TO
DISCUSS, I KNOW, IN THE CAPITOL,
BUT I’VE HEARD FIGURES NOW
TOPPING $2 TRILLION.
IS IT GETTING THAT HIGH?
HIGHER STILL?
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> WELL, IT’S HARD TO SAY ON THE
NUMBERS BECAUSE THERE ARE A LOT
THAT HAVE BEEN NEGOTIATED, NOT
AGREED TO AND WE’RE TRYING TO
FINALIZE THAT IN THE NEXT DAY OR
TWO AND CLEARLY THERE ARE BIG
PIECES TO IT.
AND A LOT OF WHAT YOU’RE LOOKING
AT, TOO, ON THE BUSINESS SIDE IS
TO TRY TO GET THE BUSINESSES TO
HOLD THEIR WORK FORCES TOGETHER.
WE’VE SEEN LARGE LAYOFFS, BUT A
LOT OF COMPANIES TRYING TO MAKE
A DECISION, MAYBE THEY’VE GOT A
BANK NOTE IN THE NEXT FEW DAYS
AND THEY ALSO WANT TO KEEP AS
MUCH OF THEIR WORK FORCE, WE’RE
TRYING TO GET SOME REGULATORY
RELIEF SOMETHING WE DID AFTER
KATRINA WAS UP TO 9 O0 DAYS
FOREBEARANCE, AND WHEN YOU
DIDN’T HAVE THE CASH FLOW.
THERE ARE A LOT OF BANKS THAT
WOULD LIKE THAT WITHOUT BEING
PENALIZED BY THE REGULATOR AND
WORK WITH LOCAL SMALL BUSINESS.
THEY COULD SAY, WE KNOW YOU HAVE
NO REVENUE, YOU CAN PUSH IT OFF
FOR THREE MONTHS AND THE SAME
THING FOR FAMILIES WITH
METROPOLITANS --
MORTGAGES.
>> I’M CURIOUS WHAT YOU MAKE OF
A LOT OF THE MEASURES, THEY’RE
MEANT TO REASSURE BUSINESSES AS
MUCH AS THE FEDERAL RESERVE AND
CUT ITS INTEREST RATE TO ZERO IS
MEANT TO REASSURE THE MARKETS.
THE MARKETS AS YOU KNOW,
CONGRESSMAN HAVE BEEN
COLLAPSING.
ONE OF OUR WORST WEEKS CERTAINLY
GOING BACK TO THE FINANCIAL
CRISIS, ARE YOU WORRIED THAT
THIS, FINANCIALLY, AT LEAST, IS
GETTING OUT OF CONTROL?
>> I’M VERY WORRIED ABOUT HOW
IT’S HAVING AN IMPACT, BOTH
SHORT-TERM AND LONG-TERM.
AND I THINK THE BIGGEST
UNCERTAINTY YOU’RE SEEING IN THE
MARKETS, THEY DON’T KNOW WHEN
THINGS COME BACK.
WE’RE GOING TO COME BACK,
WHETHER IT’S WEEKS AND SOME
PEOPLE ARE WONDERING IF IT’S
LONGER THAN THAT.
I HOPE IT’S NOT.
AND I THINK ONCE YOU HAVE A
CLEAR IDEA AND OTHERS TALK ABOUT
THE SPIKE AND YOU DON’T WANT THE
HOSPITAL SYSTEM OVERWHELMED, BUT
WEEM WANT TO-- WANT TO KNOW IF I
GOING TO BE A FEW MORE WEEKS.
A LOT OF THEM THINK IS THIS
GOING TO BE MONTHS?
AND WE COULD ADDRESS IT ON THE
FRONT END AND GET TO A POINT
WHEN IT’S TIME TO GET BACK OPEN
THERE ARE BUSINESSES AND JOBS
AND THAT’S WHAT WE’VE GOT TO
FOCUS ON THIS RELIEF PACKAGE.
NEIL: VERY GOOD HEARING YOU.
AND A LOT OF THIS GOES BACK TO
WHEN YOU WERE SHOT AND BOTH
PARTIES, A LOT OF WAY THAT THAT.
AND THIS GOODWILL SEEMS TO BE